Belts around the world have never dreamed of it, and the keyboard is growing.
There is not
You guys too.
I am the best today.
I want to tell you how to make a lot of money.
Mobile app developers are dreaming of a big hit today
We are burning.
How do you want to earn more money?
Hello, I am running today.
I'll show you how to make a lot of revenue.
There are two general ways a mobile app can make money.
Selling apps in your app and exposing 909 photos.
Korean developers often think that the sales revenue of the item is the most.
According to external statistics such as the actual idc, m 4
Item sales of cabbage m 4 advertising sales account for about 5 percent
So you can advertise either, so in Admob these two
We have released 8 rabbit items.
If you use item sales buildings, users who are likely to pay for ad mob
I want you to pick an automatic.
Then they show me all the same things that stimulate your purchase.
For the rest of the users, you can show the ad mob ads on the same spot.
Targeted sexual ads have a high nodule, which leads to an increase in sales of items.
At the same time, you'll also get ad revenue.
The announcement will never be separated.
So let's see how this article maneuver works in ad mob
I'll tell you.
The item sales department utilizes the ad mob house advertising function.
You can think of advertising my items free of charge in Nap
So n 4 Create an interstitial at the right place.
You can create a sales item for the
Please set me up.
So if you're targeting only those people who will automatically pay for that ad,
See
Maximize your profits by showing ad mob ads to other users
It's possible
I do not want to be rich by using it quickly.
So let's use it once. Let's set it up first.
Please visit the add-on main page
c If you do not have an affair account yet, click the link below
Please sign up
Main Page 4 Click Monetize After selecting your app
Make a single interstitial
If you do not know, please refer to the following article
So this time, it's time to make an ad to sell the item.
Please click to advertise. Please select the Leah House Advertisement campaign here.
If you are new to this feature, you can see another screen.
Click here to create a new brother election.
Then select your app and the ad recommendation format is either an item sales text ad or
You can choose one of the item sales image studies
Please refer to the following article for details of the remaining settings
look
So this is all set up for the sale of the item.
Now that you've applied your app's code,
You can increase your advertising revenue all at once.
Let's have an Android specialist who can help you apply the code.
Teacher, please.
Did you hear the story of Choi Si-young, manager of WoA item sales advertisement?
With just a few clicks you can use both item sales and ad mob ads.
It is so wonderful
I have to apply my ship, too. Hi.
Yes.
All developers who are wondering how to get more
We'll show you how to apply an item sales ad to your app.
I will give you.
Applying item sales ads is not difficult
In particular, if you are already using a full-blown ad,
A few weeks of modifying and implementing a callback function can be applied quickly
There is
But it seems simple, but the item sale advertising is various Google mobile service Google
Play Ad is something that is implemented in the language utilizing the jacks feature
As such, developers can create or connect accounts for each service.
You need to keep the keys and settings for each service.
There is a detailed help page for each product in Korean.
It would be helpful if you look at it.
So, how do you use these products in actual Android code?
Should I
Your friend Google Play for using Google's mobile services in
You can use this service easily
Item Miners are included with Google Play Services 5.0 or higher
You can add dependencies for those files as follows:
Next we will add activities for occupancy and item sales ads
Since the activities are already included in the Google Play service,
You can add a manifest simply by applying the theme as follows
And the wrong thing to buy internet items for bringing up ads
Add to master
Now is the time to write the code.
I'll load the actual ad and display it on the screen.
Let's talk about how it should be structured.
Create a WinTest well object for display and add the ad unit
Assign an id
Next, the kids use the cast d to use the l2 cast
Generate baggage
Previously there's been a Tishire Lord Ed to derive men's
I get one ad from the ad network
One ad requires the requested network connection, and before and during the ad
It may take some time
Thus, at a specific point in time, for example, immediately after a user clears the stage,
Show and request ad via loadhead method a little early if it is 10 o'clock
I think you'd better do it.
I'm finally ready to show my ad
Watching a winter gesture can invoke methods to display an interstitial page.
There is
At this time, to confirm whether the advertisement was normal, the 3rd of Izu rhythm
Please check the result.
Also, before the ads are displayed, if they register their stuff, they will be loaded with ads
The callback function will be called at the moment it appears on the screen or closes the ad window
You can use it to keep your app running while ads are showing.
You can perform tasks
Now, when a user who is likely to buy an item launches an app,
You will see the ad
If this user buys an item through an ad, it should be handled appropriately within m.
That's it.
If you register your PlayStation to express your listener,
When you're done, you can see and handle it
PlayStore Persistence Listener supports two callback methods
First of all, within the Izbeliad Perchature School bag,
I can really check the correct lighting, and my odd pulse train callback
Inside the game, we will properly reflect the purchased items in the game and use the pc plus method
You can consume items through
The arguments of the surname delivered in Nepal call speech callback include intent
Because we have a government that can verify that the purchase process went right.
I hope you will take advantage of this. Like this PlayStore Perth Listener
If you register for the implementation, you will be able to process the entire item purchase process with just a few lines of code.
can
However, in order to verify the purchase process of items in your m
If you are thinking of complicated tasks such as work, playstore Perth
May be difficult to use
In this case, there is another offer provided by the item sales ad,
You can take advantage of you
The Perth listener is called when the user presses the Buy Item button.
It is a simple listener.
PlayStorePotz Unlike in Switzerland, the developer is within the callback
You can do all the steps involved in purchasing items, such as running an item purchase activity
You can process
So far, you have to be brief about how you can
I checked.
Learn more about this on our developer site
Please refer to the developer blog,
There is a way to measure and efficiently set the target user
Another video is ready, please do not miss it
I hope that you will earn more revenue through the sale of items.
I'll see you later on the video. Thank you.
lie to me 2